and so at PAX were here rocking the 3ds
and I played a couple of new games
coming out for the 3ds one is mario kart
7 they're calling at seven which is
funny I didn't know they're going to do
as I was gonna be Mario Kart 3d
which it really plays really well I love
the way it handles personally the later
mario karts who seemed a little harder
for me maybe I'm just like dumb but it's
best mario kart you're in the back of
the line you get the three red shells
you're wiping everyone out you're in the
front of the line you get banana peels
god help yourself in Super Mario Land 3d
or is the title spells without super
mario 3d land this games a lot of fun
it's really nostalgic it has that for
when you go into a dungeon it has that
kind of overheads side view kind of like
mario RPG pizza for some odd reason i
thought mario RPG on that then the other
ones kind of have this paper mario mario
64 feel but it's all in 3d you know
whenever you get a nintendo system the
one thing you can count on except the
mario game is going to be like the solid
game I mean you have the Tanooki suit
back goombahs even get the Tanooki suit
that's kind of me I didn't know they can
become raccoon people mushroom raccoon
people that's that's a love child that
likes to which I myself a temper thought
of my one gripe in this entire game is
that the levels seem really short but if
marbles are as short as they were in the
demo I don't want to feel ripped off so
I hope those were demo size levels i
hope the a you know the VIP levels the
ones that you actually get with the
cartridge out there longer my one gripe
in the entire game other than that this
game is pretty sweet it's Mario it's
Mario
and legend of zelda skyward sword like
most other things it's a give and take
to this I like the fact that it uses the
wii motionplus controller so wherever
you move your controller link sword is
doing this but I do like the fact you
can hold up your sword you can do this
like kind of power of grayskull kind of
[ __ ] and charge it up I was doing that
like forever I like throwing that little
beetle rise one little scarabs that the
thing that kills Benny in the mummy you
can throw one of those around you can
spy around with it for some reason I was
there for like a good few minutes like
throwing this thing around just like
using it as my little spy cam I like
that look in the world we live in where
I'm playing a legend of zelda game the
coolest thing is I'm throwing the beetle
from the mummy around and that made me
content I made my year you only have a
few minutes to play the game it's a few
minutes and a legend of zelda dungeon
have you ever gotten anywhere in a
legend of zelda dungeon in just a few
short minutes now you have to allocate
three solid hours of your day and go you
know what I'm not doing anything until
as a legend of zelda dungeness be so you
get to demo it for five minutes that's
why you throw a beetle around you begin
your content with the world I do like
how the wii motionplus controller when
you're shooting the bow and arrow you
draw it back like that then you push the
button and shoots there was a spider
dangling i shot the i shot the spider
webby know like Robin Hood prince of
thieves and all that good [ __ ] that was
me splitting the arrows with the wii
motionplus controller so that in the
beetle let me tell ya I'm getting the
game because of those two things that is
a Zelda game and I'd be stupid not to
alright guys now on to the wii u
well no we you like last year Nintendo
didn't have a 3ds attacks this year
there's no with you there's no wii u and
there's no PS vita portable systems and
new systems that are coming out they
need love to give us the sub it's fact
we're legit now Seattle's kind of
awesome once a year during pax and
actually among all this and among
nintendo not happen to wii u there is
some good news a subscriber with a
substantial taste are you pissed that
there's no way you get what the buck
such language here in seattle my
subscribers have never been more awesome
actually nicole Oh who's your favorite
person who was the best person on
YouTube jeremyjahns very you punch the
camera before was that's okay though
it's okay yeah your punch was better
than mine good job